[Music]
all right this is the Fox News Alert
Paris remains on edge as one day after
Islamic extremists with ties to Isis
carried out a massive series of deadly
Terror attacks according to reports two
suspects in Friday's attack may have
immigrated to Europe through Greece as
part of the Syrian refugee movement now
right here on this program we have been
warning about the dangers of this
migrant crisis as have multiple senior
Intel officials watch this
I don't obviously put it past the likes
of isil to infiltrate operatives among
these refugees we can only query against
that which we have collected
and and so if someone has never made a
ripple in the pond in Syria in a way
that would get their Identity or their
interests reflect in our database we can
query our database until the cows come
home but we're not gonna there'll be
nothing show up because we have no
record on that person
joining us now with reaction the
director of jihad watch Robert Spencer
from the Islamic House of Wisdom Imam
Muhammad Ali alahi and the president of
act for America Brigitte Gabriel rajeet
I'm looking at a poll a year ago from
France 16 of French citizens support
Isis the population of France in terms
of the Muslim population is anywhere
estimated anywhere between eight and ten
percent we had the controversy of no-go
zones no no-go zones Etc but are we
dealing with a clash of cultures western
civilization and people that come from
countries where perhaps they grew up
under Sharia law is this now going to be
a growing problem here in the U.S if in
fact we take in refugees from Syria and
Iraq and elsewhere
it has been a problem Sean and the West
has been dealing with the war with a
clash of civilization the problem is the
West is refusing to acknowledge the fact
that we are at War despite the fact that
our enemies tell us repeatedly we are at
war with you we are at war with you we
do not like your ways we abhor your
immorality we abhor your materialism
This Is How They view us at least the
people in France were honest enough to
express their opinion we know the same
thing as happening in America today poll
after Paul have showed that and what we
are concerned about right now is these
so-called refugees that we are bringing
are people who are coming to our Shores
who do not share our values even though
they are not raised necessarily or born
into countries that adhere to Sharia law
but with the uprise of Islamic
radicalism throughout the world they are
all experiencing The Rebirth of
spiritual Islam of the Islam of Muhammad
and that's what they are gravitating to
and bringing to our Shores hey Mom let
me ask you this this question the
national head of intelligence National
Intelligence Agency James Clapper said
that when we take in among the refugee
population there will be Isis there will
be Al Qaeda that infiltrate that
population as a means of getting into
the West so my question for you is why
should America why should any country in
Europe take in any of these refugees
knowing that their enemies will
infiltrate that population
Sean I think that we are changing the
subject the refugees are the victims my
mom I don't I don't want to change
listen I asked you ask Justin why should
one trees if their intelligence or
telling them that Isis and Al-Qaeda will
infiltrate the refugee population tell
me why any of these countries should
take in any of these migrants
are common Real Enemy is Isis
Taliban nusra all this uh production of
the tech Fury terrorists theology
answering my question yeah I'm answering
my question I'm answering your question
in a sense so we have to wake up and we
have to be more serious about this real
Isis problem we have to be more
determined we have to stop this
hypocrisy and double the standard of
saying we have good terrorism batteries
good dictators and bad
dictators we have good explosion and bad
explosion from Kabul to Cairo from
Beirut to Baghdad from Pakistan to Paris
the democracy is targeted terrorist
attacks that happen around the world so
often are radical Islamic terrorists now
Hillary Clinton Robert Spencer says I
don't think we're at war with radical
Islam and the president thinks what
happened in Fort Hood is workplace
violence and these are man-called
disasters and overseas contingency
operations Robert but the reality is we
have a president that won't say the
words radical Islam we have presidential
candidates now that won't say it and
their plan is to bring in refugees from
countries without any ability to
ascertain whether or not they have our
best interests at heart or whether or
not they buy into radicalism why should
we take in any of those there's just no
way
there's no way to tell we shouldn't take
any of them we should send them all to
Saudi Arabia where there's plenty of
room and where they are it have they're
in complete commonality linguistically
culturally and religiously there is
absolutely no reason you know why the
Saudis are not taking them because they
know and they say openly that there are
terrorists among them the Islamic State
we should recall last February Isis said
they were going to send 500 000 refugees
into Europe that was before The Crisis
began in September one of their
operatives said we've already sent four
thousand jihadis into Europe and the
Lebanese education Minister just weeks
ago estimated that there were 20 000
active jihadis among the refugees in his
country and is absolutely impossible to
tell the jihadis from genuine refugees
and we shouldn't take even one of them
but the denial as you point out Sean
it's Universal the presidential
candidates are saying this is not a
problem not a threat and we should bring
these people in solely on humanitarian
grounds we're setting ourselves up for a
Jihad attack on the scale of Paris in
New York or Washington or LA or Chicago
or all of them but that is unfair that
is very immoral and unethical
irresponsible statement because the
refugees the refugees don't want to come
to United States who caused this problem
you just mentioned Saudi Arabia a
satanic system that is source of
providing ideology and might and
Military and media for Isis and other
terrorists and look we are friendly with
Saudi Arabia and we are fighting those
who are fighting Isis you are fighting
Hezbollah we are fighting Surya we are
fighting
those who are fighting Isis when we are
friendly with the source of this problem
who is this King Salman to condemn Isis
and he is
Sean people people ask me all the time
what can we do to make sure that these
Syrian refugees do not come to our
country and I tell them go to our
website act for america.org we have a
petition right now to the leadership of
Congress to stop Obama from bringing
refugees into the country sign up to get
our action alerts we we now know that
under the law any community that is
going to bring refugees into that
Community must hold under the law public
hearing we are notifying people
Nationwide when these public hearings
are held so citizens who are concerned
about this issue can show up and express
their opinion for america.com
for being with us
we appreciate your time thank you coming
up next